let me give you one piece of advice
about your personal story no one cares
no one cares about you or your story and
now we insert one word that changes
everything
no one cares about you or your personal
story unless
that story or your experience can help
them and how do you connect your story
to them and the one way you know is the
personal pronoun that you use the most
and most ordinary speakers use I more
than any other word their opening is
this I'm so excited to be here no one
cares that you're excited I've been
thinking about this opportunity to be
with Evan all week long since he invited
me to be with you no one cares so here's
a great way to open three words you're
here because you're here because you're
a movement maker you're here because
you've got a message in you that's
burning to come out and you want to
share that and you want to monetize that
thank you
this man is a legend Mr Jill Weldon
we're going to talk about speaking how
to turn it into a career well movement
makers great to see you you know you're
here because you want to be an even
better speaker and monetize that thing
getting paid to speak is a whole
different transition than using speaking
to grow your business and I think we
need to talk about that because the most
important thing is you want to think
about how can you monetize speaking two
ways by getting paid a fee to speak or
using the platform to generate income as
a coach as an author as an entrepreneur
and in many cases generating
substantially more money by doing that
than you could by a speaker's fee so
with that said think about you as hiring
a speaker why would you if you had a
business or a company or an association
and you wanted a speaker
why would you bring in a speaker
to bring information to your audience to
your members that they don't have access
to
which means you need to know something
that people don't know and as an example
this guy next to me Evan we're part of
Genius Network when Joe polish brought
him in Evan knew more about using
YouTube videos and creating them with
almost a half a billion views three
million followers
I we don't know anybody that's done that
so that was very important and that's
why an introduction is important what
gives them the ability to speak on that
subject when Evan was introduced I wrote
that introduction for him here
it was amazing how receptive the
audience was now one of the things Evan
told me in preparing for this that you
have a very dramatic personal story that
as a movement maker you want to spread
what you've learned or your experience
and you share your personal story
let me give you one piece of advice
about your personal story no one cares
no one cares about you or your story and
now we insert one word that changes
everything
no one cares about you or your personal
story unless and that's the word unless
that story or your experience can help
them
and how do you connect your story to
and the one way you know is the personal
pronoun that you use the most and most
ordinary speakers use I more than any
other word their opening is this I'm so
excited to be here no one cares that
you're excited I've been thinking about
this opportunity with Heaven all week
long since he invited me to be with you
no one cares
so here's a great way to open three
words you're here because
you're here because you're a movement
maker you're here because you've got a
message in you that's burning to come
out and you want to share that and you
want to monetize that
that's the difference so look at your
last email to a client or a customer
Circle how many times you said I and how
many times you said you
an email is a presentation a video is a
presentation a phone call is a
presentation a zoom training call like
this is a presentation it's got to start
somewhere it's got to end somewhere
and it's got to be about them it's not
about you you already know the truth
you've experienced them now with that
said in our first six and a half minutes
together let's stop and open it up to
any questions comments or thoughts you
have my goal is to get on stages live in
front of people I've done videos and
podcasts but I really want to be on a
stage and one of the things I'm curious
is how many different speeches did I
have should I have one
or should I adjusting and adapting to
the different audiences in different
stages uh yes
I yes to both yeah well the last thing
you said is the most important should I
be adjusting and adapting to different
audiences so Evan mentioned you know
I've been paid over three thousand times
to speak never did I give the same talk
okay
now ninety percent of it eighty percent
of it seventy percent might have been
similar to other messages but unless
it's relevant to the people you're
talking to
it's not going to connect so there was
an adage in the beginning days of
professional speaking to have one talk
and change audiences just give the same
talk over and over and hope it fit and
in many cases speakers were able to come
up with good material people loved it
and they became successful at it that
was not the approach that I used my
Approach was based on what I told you
nobody cares about you they only care
about what do you know that's going to
help me
and if you think about these three words
what do you know that can help me meet a
need that I have
overcome a fear or concern or a worry
that I have or reinforce a victory or
success that I'm presently experiencing
and if you can do that meet a need
overcome a fear reinforce a victory
then if you knew that about your
audience you could adapt your material
to do that so Evan told me about you as
a group that many of you are coaches
you're entrepreneurs you're part of his
organization you've got a power within
you that you want to share with other
people and speaking is going to be one
way to do it
so yes you could have one talk that you
adapt or if you have expertise in more
than one area you could do that so I had
many different areas I specialized in
sales in leadership and in personal
development those are three very broad
topics but over 48 years of developing
materials so I figured I had 70 hours of
stage time without repeating anything
but it was customized and one other
thing to think of in my entire career I
never had a demo video
never work with an agent or salesperson
never did any marketing didn't even know
what marketing was until I joined genius
Network eight years ago and met people
like Evan
all I did was an amazing presentation
they hired me again or referred me to
someone else and that's how I built the
career
some hired me 70 times 60 times 50 times
in big companies to use that material in
different parts of their organization
but the key was
it wasn't about me
it was about them and how maybe this
experience that I brought could be used
by them to meet a need overcome a fear
or reinforce a victory how how do you
give a speech
that goes like straight to the heart
that connects with them
um inside here that makes them like
feel something well how do you connect
with anybody on an emotional level
I think one of the ways you do that is
when an audience knows that the speaker
understands
their situation
I know you have been everybody on this
call has been in the audience and you've
been Rose you've been in the audience
many times have you ever heard a speaker
where you're thinking to yourself they
don't have a clue what I do
that that has nothing to do with me
you're not going to connect on an
emotional level
so knowing just using our experience
here what Evan told me that you Rose you
have something inside of you a life
experience a trauma a tragedy a victory
something you did that has moved you
forward in your life and you feel that
this experience you've had or knowledge
that you gained can help other people
and you want to share that with others
is that true about you yes okay all
right now without knowing what that is
I don't care
you're not important to me now I don't
mean that literally now with you because
you're part of Evan's group I love you
but one of the things you need to think
of is how can you connect that
experience with what they're going
through
so let's just say the audience is part
of two organizations that have merged
together Acquisitions and mergers are
happening all the time and somebody in
one of those organizations knew about
you and they wanted you to come in to
help make this transition even better
you need to know what are the
differences in the two companies what
are the people in those seats thinking
about is my job going to be cut are they
going to take somebody from the other
company and I'm out is my pay going to
go down that's what's important to them
and so many times speakers talk about
what's important to them as a speaker
this is my favorite subject no one cares
here's a subject you're going to find so
helpful today
that should be the tone of your message
and if you think about that if you can
create a message that connects with the
people you're talking about or talking
to they're going to want to hear more
from you
which means they want to hire you again
or they're going to refer you to
somebody else
those are the best ways to grow your
speaking business
today we are talking about business
development how to use content to bring
in immediate business and we're going to
talk about client Outreach the first
strategy of client Outreach involves
zero content so you don't even have to
make content if you're struggling at the
point right now where like I need to
make money right now it's not working
you don't even have to make content yet
and I'm going to show you the strategy
that we've used multiple times that I've
invested into entrepreneurs and we've
done one high six figure business two
mid six figure business one low
six-figure business that's Zach he hit
his path for six figures in three weeks
of doing this when I'm looking at Zach
or Drew or Beau or Jeremy the people
that I've invested in and we go through
this process I want at least a two
thousand dollar a month fine thinking
who can pay us two thousand dollars a
month and part of the problem with a lot
of our Outreach is you're targeting
people who cannot pay you so if you're
targeting people who don't have any kind
of budget they might have a need but if
they don't have budget you're not making
money but if it's hard for them to pay
fifty dollars a month that's not an
ideal client for you so we target people
who the minimum thousand a month and an
ideal is 3 500 plus per month okay so
I'm going to show you the process that
we go through here so Step One is make a
list of clients who can't pay you right
and what I want to do in our breakout
sessions is brainstorm together who are
the types of potential people who are
potential clients for us or partners for
us so we're making a list of clients who
can actually pay us
who can afford a thousand bucks a month
500 bucks a month 2 000 bucks a month
3500 bucks a month right uh some of the
cases it's five figures per month but
who can afford to pay you at least a
couple thousand dollars a month for the
thing you're going to be providing right
it starts to really change who we're
going often who we're targeting
so again ideally two thousand dollars
plus per month
and this is where it's often easier to
go up to businesses than it is to go
after consumers
so not a lot of individuals will be able
to pay you two thousand dollars a month
but businesses can't
if you're solving a business problem for
people and it's really helping them
it's easier to get the money because
they have budget and it's easier to
maintain it so that it's happening every
month
every month every month every month
every month every month the first brand
deal that I got was I was writing
content
for a big telecommunications company
here in Canada and I was I was writing a
bunch of content and trying to sell my
content and um through articles and
wasn't making any money and waiting on
advertisements to start to come in but
you need huge scale to do that and says
okay well I can I can write great
articles and instead of just writing for
my website instead of just writing for
one person I'm going to write for a
corporate blog
and they paid me I think the first one
was 500 bucks to do a one-off and then
that led to a thousand bucks and 1500
bucks and 2 000 bucks and I kept
increasing the value and they kept
increasing how much they paid me but
because it's a business it fits in well
they have budget you're solving a
problem and
it's an ongoing problem so so they need
you to continue to ongoingly solve it
for them okay so I'm thinking about our
clients I want you thinking people who
can actually afford to pay you part of
the biggest problem is we're not talking
to people who can actually
pay us they just don't have the budget
to pay us
okay I'm looking at Peter here he makes
these awesome
um animation videos of me you know that
he shares on Instagram cool approach
businesses and say hey I do these
animation videos
I will make a video per week for you or
per day for you I don't know how long it
takes Peter to make these videos and
it's going to cost 2 000 bucks a month
right we start to get clients because
we're solving a problem
okay so that's step one make a list step
two is we're gonna Outreach to them and
offer three big Ideas hey I've got three
big ideas for how you can blank so
inside of YouTube world if you're
looking at Zach or Drew or Jeremy where
we're doing YouTube Consulting with
people it's like I've got three big
ideas for how you can go from 10 000
subscribers to a hundred thousand
subscribers or if you're at 100 to go
from a hundred thousand to five hundred
thousand subscribers if they're already
at 500 to go from 500 000 to 10 million
subscribers and so on right I've got
three big ideas for how you can get X so
what is the X you can provide people
what is the result that you're going to
be able to provide people
and you have three big ideas for how
they can accomplish that
then you reach out to them and email and
then social so email you'll be able to
find their email you may not be able to
but you're looking to see if you can
find your email and then social media
wherever they are active on social and
maybe that's Twitter maybe that's
LinkedIn maybe that's Instagram who
knows maybe that's uh Tick Tock where
are they actually active themselves on
social media and then that's what we're
going to be doing some Outreach to them
to say you've got your two big ideas
that you'd love to share with them
and then you go on a call with them not
everybody says yes right this becomes a
if you only have three people on your
list that's a problem right we need to
build a big list of people so that in
the Outreach process some people will
never see it some people will ignore you
and then some people say yes and they
hop on a call and then you go through
your ideas
from that call
we're just given the value we're just
here are three big Ideas like take it
run with it go do it yourself amazing if
you need help I can help you do it too I
have a business that does this but here
are your three big Ideas so if
somebody's coming on a call to talk
about their YouTube channel to go from
50 000 subscribers to 100 here are the
three big Ideas go do it you have a team
awesome execute it yourself
I can help or Zach can help or Drew can
help or Jeremy can help right
from there you'll get 30 to 50 percent
of people who then want to sign up and
go do the thing with you if you've
targeted your list a lot
some people may not want to do it some
people may not be ready some people may
not be in the right spot yet and So for
anybody who we all hop on a call with
who then doesn't say yes right away we
add them to what we call our value
emails list
and on the value emails list every two
weeks we send a value email around the
thing that they care about
Okay so
in the YouTube world uh Drew might send
an email about thumbnails right okay
here are the latest findings we have
about thumbnails or here's an experiment
that we ran on title split test or
here's how you can use your newsletter
list to grow your YouTube channel right
it's it's just value it's not hey are
you ready to buy yet hey hello I'm still
here can you hire me right so we're not
doing follow-up emails there are no
follow-up emails they they buy on the
call
or they don't and if they don't they're
added to the client to the value emails
list and then every two weeks you send a
value email around the thing that you're
an expert at
just giving pure value and then the last
sentence can be hey and if you're ready
to blank right if you're ready to grow
your YouTube channel I'm happy to help
but it's not a sales email it's a value
you're educating and you're teaching and
what some people will do
maybe they take that email and they just
do the work themselves cool they give it
to their team and say hey copy what this
person told me to do great some people
look at and say wow you're really an
expert at this and you're still giving
me tons of value I want to how can I
work with you how can I hire you and for
some people it's just a matter of timing
like they're swamped they're overwhelmed
they've got a million things going on
and they're not ready but now they are
and every time we've done this when
we've built up a list of people you hop
on some calls and some people who don't
say yes cool you add them to the list
and then you add send the value add
emails it might be somebody that you
talked to six months ago but now they're
ready
and maybe they've been seeing your
emails every two weeks or six months and
they never responded but then now they
respond and they say I'm ready
so we often get caught on this trap of
like following up and waiting for people
don't wait for people go out and do more
Outreach
and now they're getting the value add
email every two weeks and off that list
is always somebody that you can that
comes back and says yes I was just
talking to Zach yesterday like should I
should I
drum up more business before the end of
the year it's like the easiest way to do
is just send out the value email
those people are reading the list who
know you who you've talked to who you've
done a quick audit for of their YouTube
channel send out that value email
and so what it does is keep you top of
mind the whole point here is to stay top
of mind for that you know they're
interested but it's not their most
important priority they have a million
other things that they're worried about
but in three months maybe it does become
their top priority and you've been
educating them for the past three months
over and over and over again so the
whole point is to stay top of mind so
that when they're ready you're the
person they come and they want to work
with
so the three points are make a list of
clients who can pay you this is the big
one because most of us are targeting
people who can't afford to pay us a
thousand two thousand dollars a month
offer them three big ideas on a call
and then add them to the value email
list if they don't sign up right away
big movements big missions Big Ideas big
things in front of you we want to go
change the world and we need help doing
it you know I think one of the
challenges that we face is we try to do
everything ourselves you're trying to do
everything yourself you're trying to
wake up do your morning routine you know
watch your videos put the music on and
just go out and do it and that's great
yes awesome and one of the fastest ways
to grow is to find people who already
have your audience
we're already talking to your customers
and find a way to work together
doing your grind doing your calls doing
your emails creating your content yes I
love it and when you can get the right
collaborations and Alliance Partners it
can really turbo speed your movement
it may take a little longer to get it
off the off the ground Alliance
Partnerships are one of the hardest
things to get going
but once you do that could be an ongoing
source of attention of traffic of leads
of customers for you forever so that's
what we're talking about today I'm so
excited let's dive in think about who
you want to talk to who you want to
connect with who if they knew who you
were would make a meaningful impact on
your business
if this person said you have to check
out Frank Villas art would make a
meaningful impact
on your business trying to splashing the
peace signs we love you Frank
think about those people okay that's who
we need to start connecting with that's
we need to start hanging out with but
then the question becomes well how do I
get to know these people because I don't
have connections I don't know anybody I
remember when I first went uh in my very
very first business I went to the bank
and asked for help
and he said well do you need what you
need a loan like oh I don't know I'm
just starting my business you know your
bank you're here to help me right I need
help
they said no we we give out loans but
you need to have at least three years in
business before you can really qualify
unless you want to put a personal
guarantee on it and so that kind of shut
down my my hopes like oh okay I guess
it's gonna be a lot harder than I
thought I was going to be getting into
this so how do you get access to these
people right step one is you want to
hang out where they hang out and what
you want to do is look for the platform
where they are the most involved so
everybody all the people that you want
to connect with they're on social media
right that's that's the beauty of living
in 2021
2022 2023 they're on social media
they're more accessible than ever
the traditional roots of trying to track
down a phone number
right is now impossible don't worry
about that but you can connect with
people on Instagram or on YouTube or on
Twitter on clubhouse but most people are
everywhere think about your own
experience you're probably everywhere
you probably have an account on all
these platforms but you're not actually
involved
and for the bigger people it's most
likely their teams who are doing most of
the stuff
so what you want to do is look for the
platform where they are the most
involved personally not just in posting
like great they're posting on Twitter
they're posting on YouTube awesome where
they actually personally involved in the
discussion
the easiest way to find that out is by
the comments
where are they actually responding to
people's comments
where are they actually involved in the
discussion
and not just their team but it's them
that's where you want to hang out
because you can spend lots of time
hanging out
and just consuming the content
but we want to be hanging out in the
same room that they're actually hanging
out and you might not be invited to all
the big parties in the fancy Jets and
you know whatever else
but social media is a part that's open
to everybody
you need to be hanging out where you're
not just Heroes and mentors and Masters
you can learn from but collaborators are
hanging out
okay so I want to tell a quick story
about Mark Jagger he's a fellow Movie
Maker friend of mine for over a decade
Mark has an ambition to be the world's
greatest host he wants to host people he
wants to host people on stage he wants
all those people having good
conversations Marcus had a podcast on
and off I don't know for five years
seven years I don't know he's had a
podcast on and off forever
nothing ever really took off because in
just starting a podcast you're one of
many
you're one of many
it's hard to stand up
so his next step was to collaborate with
me
Clubhouse came out I actually pushed him
to say mark this is Audio Only You Love
Audio Only You need to get on clubhouse
now
while it's still young while you can
still stand out while there's still so
much demand and so little good Supply
you need to get on now and start having
these conversations and start hosting
rooms so step one was him to create a
clubhouse account step two was him to
start using my account where we're
leveraging all of the videos that we've
done on YouTube and broadcast them to
Clubhouse
what led to that happening was Grant
Cardone Pops in the room
Les Brown Pops in a room and Mark starts
having conversations with them
so he leveraged my name to create my
grant cardone's top 50 rules of success
and my Les Brown's top 50 rules for
Success broadcast him on clubhouse right
Mark was just doing the tech behind it
leverage my name to do it Grant Pops in
the room
twice
and Mark then has a conversation
with Grant
getting access to Grants is very
difficult if you were to email his
office and say hey I'd love to talk to
grant for a couple minutes
good luck making that happen right
but because Grant's attention was on
clubhouse at the moment it was an easy
way for Mark to start to have that
conversation Les Brown this is an even
better story Les Brown pops in
Mark has another great conversation
which leads to less wanting to partner
up which led to us doing
two more less brown only q and A's
whereas me Mark Les and his son John
Leslie the first one lasted a couple
hours the second one we did we had the
we had to narrow down the time scope
because I had the runs it was like an
hour an hour and a half but now Mark
is hosting
Les Brown
on his channel where he spent seven
years or whatever podcasting not really
getting traction now all of a sudden is
hosting the Les Brown
because he's hanging out where Les Brown
is hanging out
you have to be where your audience not
just where your audience with the people
you want to collab with are hanging out
that's the keys he's got the skill set
he always had the skill set
now Mark this weekend
is flying to Les Brown's event and
helping host his event live on stage
with Les Brown
right yeah you guys can top that up how
cool is that
he went from just having years of
podcasting not getting any traction to
then getting on clubhouse leveraging
leveraging my content
getting to connect with less hosting
Less in a couple of Clubhouse rooms to
now being invited to go host with les
live at One or less Brown's events and
Les Brown to me is one of the greatest
of all time young Les Brown is the
greatest speaker of all time in my books
where he falls for you is open for
debate but I mean he's got to be in the
top 10 of all time now Mark is
facilitating those conversations because
he was hanging out where they hang out
this is how quickly it can happen
when you start to get into the right
circles
okay
Evan tinsman so Evan tinsman came this
is Evan movement makers the first
movement maker Evan tinsman was the
first movie maker he came to my event in
Pittsburgh this was his first video on
his YouTube channel if you go to his
channel and you go go oldest videos see
this video which was him January 2019 I
went to Pittsburgh it was cold and a lot
and I kicked off my event my tour this
is where I broke my neck we did 90 days
on the road all that stuff 23 cities
this is the first stop this is Evan's
first video it's 20 seconds long
don't make 20 second long videos on
YouTube guys you know now we know we
know but this is great this is just him
just before I get started that's me
about to get started on stage and I've
been just doing a quick tour of the room
he came to thank me for all the videos
that I had done I never met him before
this point but he had watched all of my
content or a good chunk of my content he
came just to think to say thank you he
knew I was coming to Pittsburgh this is
a chance to hang out we're the people
you want to connect with are hanging out
and really the motivation to come was
just just to say hi and say thank you
that's why he showed up
it led to him join in movement makers
led to him being a part of our
Mastermind now was for one year plus
members
and let them me giving him a quote for
his YouTube channel you know how many
people hit me up every day asking hey
can you be a testimonial hey can you
write the forward for my book hey can
you review my product hey and it's not
that I don't want to it's that I don't
know you
you know I don't know you I I
don't like giving recommendations to
people who I've never met
even if they've been a hardcore loyal
fan of my channel if you haven't ever
contributed anything I I can't I don't
know who you are so
we took this picture in Pittsburgh
I then hung out with Evan the next day a
little bit and I gave him a quote if you
want the steps to have a greater impact
follow-up in Kinsman says Evan
Carmichael Evan and Evan
right
because he came to where I was hanging
out
that's you wanted you make your list of
the top hundred people that you want to
connect with and then you're staying on
top of where are they hanging out both
virtually right
Mark did it to get the Grant Cardone and
Les Brown through Clubhouse Evan did it
by getting to me in person because I had
an event happening there
one other quick example this is Jeremy
who came to my thought Leadership
Academy this is this was the this is
what I did before Movie Makers I had
twice a year people coming to Toronto uh
and we trained 15 people at a time how
to be thought leaders uh you can see
Alex down here at the bottom Alex was
one of my my trainers as well uh but the
circle there is Jeremy and Jeremy came
at the time he was
uh earning minimum wage at a grocery
store stocking shelves hating his job
hating his life saved up his money I
didn't know any of his story till he
told me afterwards but saved up this
money to come to this event this is
three days a couple thousand dollars uh
and thought I need to hang out where
everyone is hanging out because Evan's
videos have impacted my life and got me
on a personal development Journey right
when he was struggling with
frustration is life he went to YouTube
typed in something like how do I make
money
and started finding my videos and it led
him down this course of personal
development
so I really liked him he was the
youngest one there he was 20 maybe just
20 21 at this time
um hanging with a bunch of you know more
grown adults
and I really talked to him and I really
liked him
and it led to us starting the business
together
and I remember I love this Vibe he told
me his story and I was on my tour and I
was thinking about him because he had
asked me Evan I want to spend more time
with you I came here to hang out with
you we're both in Toronto tell me what I
can do to spend more time with you I
will walk your dog I will clean your car
I will cut your grass I will do whatever
you need me to do I don't have very many
skills yet because I'm still young and
developing but whatever you want to do
whatever you need me for just I'm here
let me know and I told them dude I love
your energy I love your Vibe I don't
need someone to walk like dogs you know
at least I'm gonna wash my car I don't I
don't I'm in a condo I don't have a lawn
but but the the vibe stock
you know the vibe stuck with me and so
when I'm doing my tour I'm driving
through the desert uh on my way to uh
New Mexico
and in the in the desert I had this idea
I'm gonna teach Jeremy how to do YouTube
I'm going to teach Jeremy how to be a
YouTube consultant
and I told Nina we need to get a two
percent difference like immediate action
I did action let's go I told Nina we
need Jeremy on a call right now
because if if we can't get him on a call
by the time I get to
Arizona not Arizona to New Mexico my
spot I see Frank I think in Arizona uh
if we can't get there in time
then I said I'm probably in a different
viable in a different Zone like when
you're in the zone you have to start
taking that immediate action that's
where your Genius really comes out so we
got Jeremy on a Facebook call and I told
him my idea
and I still had two more months of my
tours like I can't do anything with you
for another two months because I'm I'm
I'm doing my tour but here's what you
need to do I'm going to send you all
sorts of resources my videos other
people's videos I want you to study
everything I want you to do your own
research into YouTube and the algorithm
and when I come back I'm going to mentor
and train you even more to build this
business
and he did right and we caught him off
guard he was out here I think he was
working his shift it's like yeah yeah I
mean I mean what do you think what
happened
shells at this grocery store and now
he's got a half a million dollar
business
you know half a million a year
inside of
a year and a half two years of doing
this working with some of his Heroes
because he hung out where the people
that he wanted to hang out with were
right he wanted to meet me and he hung
with me this isn't just like oh Evan
Carmichael's so special this is this is
everybody this is you can you can get a
lot closer to touching your dreams when
you're hanging out with the people who
can make a difference for you Jeremy
knew nothing about YouTube at the time
now he's coaching some of the biggest
YouTube channels in the world
and thought leadership on how they can
grow their channels
he uh burned his apron he had to wear
this apron every day you know there's
this outfit you burn the aprons like I'm
never going back there and he had this
really emotional moment where he made
more in one month than he did an entire
year working you know full-time as a
grocery store clerk right
um and it's not the skill set because he
had none it's just the desire and the
willingness to show up
the daily to do and not to-do list now
I've done the to-do list a lot of times
the not to do part of it though was the
interesting thing that I had to really
think about and took me a lot longer
than expected so let me start with the
easy stuff the to-do list so I'm going
to walk you through what I do every day
every morning uh and and the different
calendars that I have and I'm going to
take it deeper than I've ever taken it
on any any presentation or speech my
morning starts with no alarm
so the to do is no alarm
and I'll usually go to bed at the same
time you go to bed around 11 and read
and then fall asleep maybe 11 30. but I
wake up with no alarm and I haven't
woken up to an alarm
I don't know maybe in a decade uh now if
I'm speaking and I have to be on stage
in the morning or traveling or something
then sure but day to day no alarm I just
basically let my body get the rest of
the needs so yesterday I woke up at
eight something this morning I woke up
at five something
I wake up when my body wakes up some
nights I need more rest some nights I
don't need as much rest and so I get up
right and so
um I I delayed the start of my day where
nothing really happens has to happen
until 10 o'clock so that I can get the
sleep that I need in my life Susie says
absolutely agree with that I mean I work
for everybody but telling you what works
for me
next the first thing I do after I wake
up
is intention for the day
I wake up you know I got lines on my
face I got stuff in my eyes what day is
it I don't even remember what is my
intention for the day this is the first
thing that I do so I go to the bathroom
and in the bathroom I'm looking at my
calendar for what's happening today
and setting the intention okay oh today
what day is today it's Thursday it's
public facing day what's my intention I
have movement makers up first amazing
this is going to be great what's my
intention I want to serve the people
here in this group I want to help I want
to try to get the things that are inside
my head and and put into your head so
you can then spread your message out and
get it to other people's heads and so
what's the intention and different days
have different intentions for me even
even inside a day you might have
different intentions
the the background on my cell phone you
probably you probably can't see it too
small but it says remember your
intention
remember you're in it's a constant
reminders moves what is my intention for
the day for this moment for right now
because if you wake up most people wake
up like an accident with zero intention
and you got hopes and dreams and
Ambitions and something inspires you and
you hope that makes a difference and it
might but we forget our intention
so when you live an intentional day it's
totally different than when you're
living an accidental day
next 30 breaths and then coal 10 cold
splashes on my face so 30 breasts is is
uh Wim Hof style so it'll be
like that 30 breaths just to start
getting some airflow going and then I I
will take the coldest water while I'm
doing that I have water on running and
I'll just then splash it on my face
just to wake up like good morning we set
Our intention no time like the present
to go kick us off let's go so 30 breaths
10 cold splashes every day then water
the goal is to drink one of these a day
I am about here since I woke up at five
so I'm about halfway through
a gallon a day you're dehydrated when
you wake up it's really hard to have
energy when you don't have water inside
you so super quick water then I do an
Eda scan and I don't know if you guys
have heard of this this was introduced
to me by Deepak Chopra when I did an
interview with him
I don't know about a month ago or a
couple weeks ago on the channel where
it's part of the Fitbit watch so Nina
and I both have the Fitbit watch and you
basically cover it with your hand and it
tracks your heartbeat
and the the shortest Eda scan you can do
is two minutes for them and your the
goal is just to calm your mind relax
just sit down and
have intention and and just let go
Whatever anxiety you might have and then
it'll track your heartbeat over the
course so I can easily get my heartbeat
down from you know 80 90 to 60.
in two minutes
so every morning I just do a quick Eda
scan
um to remind myself then I take the dogs
out get some sun get some sun on your
face it makes a huge huge huge
difference having a dog forces that
but what on days where I don't take the
dogs out in the morning I don't get sun
I don't have as much energy
there's just something of getting some
even here in Toronto when it's it's
freezing and cold in Canada and it's
starting to get a little bit nice now
but even in the winter just getting
outside getting some fresh air even just
that idea of getting out of your your
home
changes the energy State when you come
back
for anybody who works at home this can
be really hard is that you there's no
separation between
waking up to then going to work
things blur too much so having some kind
of routine to make that transitioner
easier you're basically leaving the home
and coming back and when you're coming
back you're getting ready to go work
sun is vitamin D says Frank I also
stretch so this is going to be me every
time I'm outside because I'm standing on
the trampoline all day long and I'm
doing 20 to 40 000 jumps a day my
hamstrings get super tight so anytime
I'm outside with the dogs I'm stretching
out my hamstrings so if you see me doing
this I'm okay just getting my stretches
in
um exercise so then I'll go for a walk
or a run sometimes with Nina or
sometimes if she's not awake then I'll
go learn so this morning was no nina
time she woke up late so I went by
myself went for a run and I'll if I'm
with Nina then we'll we'll usually do a
walk they'll be you know 45 minutes and
we talk with the dogs if I'm not with
Nina I'm I'm walking faster or running
although Nina can walk really really
really fast for a little person she
walks faster than me so that's that's
epic and I usually have the top 10 rules
in my in my ear as I'm running or
walking getting outside getting some
exercise learning as well right what
what is the thing that gets you inspired
motivated confident ready for action
bold courageous and then doing that
thing in the morning
so I I make my videos still for me I
consume my video still for me and I want
that in my life because
uh so today was Tom bily today I was
listening to Tom Billy and every time I
listen to Tom bail you I get a little
more bold a little more courageous a
little more spark and so not just hoping
that that happens designing and
Engineering it into your day every day
demanding it
uh and then the latest finish is 10. so
all that has to happen by 10. that can
go super quick
or it can take more time again depends
on when I wake up so from if I wake up
at eight something I go super fast
through but it still gives me the time
to get through it because I don't have
to be done until 10.
this morning I woke up at five something
super easy to get through all this stuff
but I don't set a start time for
anything
because I don't know when I'm gonna wake
up so there's not the pressure if I have
to be outside by X time
I have to be done by 10 and there's
there's no situation where I'm not
waking up by 10. I can't sleep in that
long so this is pretty much
every day
it's pretty much every day
um weekdays for sure most weekends every
day
that's my morning routine my to-do list
the daily routine I'm not going to go
like step by step through this if you
want to go deeper we can on any days
even questions but this is what a
weekday typically looks like wake up the
one routine that you just saw 10 o'clock
I'm done right 10 o'clock I have to be
done that's music and daily websites
music like why we have Zan here before
you guys get on because look at me so
excited music is the fastest way to
change your state
right and and
Alex comes on and starts singing I can
see clearly now so then Zayn starts
playing the song Tess says she loves
Calypso so Zayn starts putting on that
music for her Zen knows I like salsa so
then he plays that like when you when
you play music that you like that would
force you like Nina was doing her
gardening stuff I was sitting here or
standing here salsa comes on we have to
go dance right there are songs that when
they come on it forces you to get up and
move
and when you do that and make it a part
of your morning routine it can change
your entire outlook on the days if I
don't have the music I'm just not as
energetic not as ready to go so what I
do is I have it says Daily website says
25 to 30 websites that I load every day
just to check in on things the first
website
is my playlist so I have a believe
playlist on my YouTube channel it's it's
open it's free you guys can look at it
if you want it doesn't really matter
what's on my playlist it's more what's
on your playlist what would you want to
have there and you could do that today
design your playlist so that tomorrow
when you wake up you can just put it on
and it will force you to get out of your
groggy state
because these are songs that would have
to make you get out of your chair think
of the songs that if they came on it
would get you out of your chair we all
have those start your day with it makes
a huge difference 10 30 to 1 3 125 is is
a work chunk and that depends on what
I'm doing for the day Thursdays public
facing day so this is this is why
movement makers is at 10 30.
it's no surprise that's why we're here
it's my work chunk number one so on
different days I have different tasks
but it's always these work chunks
130 to 155 I'm checking email and I'm
doing uh some Social Media stuff two
o'clock IG live uh or insiders group
Live
um so that's my break in between of like
of my different work chunks
um then 230 to 255 and this is every
weekday this is Monday to Friday uh I'll
go out with Nina and we'll go right now
since it's getting warmer we'll just go
to the park take the dogs get some sun
we connect how was your morning because
I'm I'm pretty
locked in
for that morning right I'm doing
whatever work I need to be doing
um I maybe I'm connecting with Nina for
working on something but it's work so we
take that 25 minutes to go outside get
some sun again be with the dogs just
something that's not work to be together
if it's super freezing cold we might
just go on the balcony taking some fresh
air just something sometime to reconnect
in the middle of the day come back work
chunk number two
it's another two and a half hours almost
of whatever work chunk for the day then
we sit down this is actually a new
addition I don't think I've even talked
about this on any video or anywhere else
where I want to try to incorporate more
sit down dinner time with Nina
I haven't sat down to eat dinner I think
since I was living with my parents
something that that I did since leaving
home since I don't know 18 whatever
whenever whenever I left
um I just default to eating Elite while
I work I've never spent time to sit down
and actually eat
um but I wanted to use that time again
to reconnect with Nina and we carve out
it's either 25 minutes sometimes a
little bit earlier depends on how that
work chunk number two goes uh but
between five and five thirty sit down
and try not to just sit there and work
uh and you know not bring our computers
with us like actually sit at the table
and put a placemat down and and
you know silverware and actually pretend
like you're having a real meal part of
that may be because we haven't gone out
to a restaurant in a year and a half
but maybe we're missing it but also time
to connect again and be together and a
lot of these moments
it doesn't have to take a long time
right the the 25 minutes with Nina in
the afternoon and then sitting down for
dinner it doesn't have to take a ton of
time but I don't know I just find that
that's important to to connect
throughout the day not just at the end
then I stream so six o'clock I stream uh
zandeman uh is a co-host uh as well as
Drew and I play League of Legends which
is a video game while we take questions
from the audience about business and
life uh so you can see what we do if you
want tonight Ivan carmichael.live six
o'clock Zen's gonna bring more energy
um eight o'clock I I usually play
something with my son we're into
Minecraft right now or he's into
Minecraft right now so I'm learning
Minecraft right now Nina and I will then
watch a show uh right now we're watching
Arrow no we finished there watching
Flash and we're watching the new Captain
America Winter Soldier and Falcon
something like that
um 10 o'clock clean up take the dogs out
do more stretching uh take questions so
I do my 10 questions with them on
Instagram and then 11 o'clock read and
go to bed uh I'm a super slow reader my
goal is 10 pages a day if I can get that
in the half an hour then I pass it
that's a that's a daily that's my daily
to do
Eddie Pinero ladies and gentlemen what
do you got for us man what should people
what do people need to do yeah so first
of all I'm so excited to be hanging out
I put myself in the position of like
when I started YouTube if there were
three things I I could tell younger me
what would it be
and so balance story in audience so the
first one balance the balance between as
creators or people that have Brands and
stories to tell you know being authentic
and loving what we're doing and and
creating uh passionately while also
understanding the parameters of the
platform and how to win in a specific
Arena
um
so when I started paying attention to
how to win on YouTube my channel grew
and like not kind of grew at like 20x
and what I'm talking about is like
creating content so I on my channel
I write speeches I like tell stories
about life and epiphanies and look for
inspiration and sort of the day-to-day
things I did that I made like three and
a half minute videos like little almost
like little songs
when I started working with Evan he was
basically like look watch time wins on
YouTube the you know if you really want
to grow your channel you have to have
longer videos
and uh so as a Creator I had to ask
myself how do I remain authentic and and
do what feels good but also stretch that
so that I can win on YouTube and so I
started writing 10 15-minute speeches
very new to me but the channel grew like
instantly same thing with like the
titling like I loved sort of artsy
cryptic type you know how like movie
titles you don't even really know what
they mean until you watch the movie
um that's what I was doing like I could
do that I could continue but
um there's disadvantages like YouTube
doesn't know what you're talking about
it doesn't you wouldn't come up in
search it doesn't know what Niche you're
in you have to be very specific
so I started changing titles and
thumbnails and uh again saw another uh
substantial growth curve so that's the
first thing it's like understanding that
balance between as creators being
authentic and loving what we're doing
but taking the time to really learn what
wins on a platform because if you marry
the two uh you see fireworks I like that
yeah yeah well no I mean of course I
like it but it's great no it's The Head
and the Heart you know it's like my
language right it's like The Head and
the Heart where if
the head is just the strategies and like
here's what you need to do to win but if
you don't love it you're not going to
win but if you're only following your
heart and there's no strategy attached
to it too then you don't end up getting
the result and so it's like in that
combination of what you love doing with
what is actually working that you start
to get some significant results and so
this is a challenge for everybody is
that in in any of these strategies that
we give you not just today but in all of
all the movement makers it's figuring
out how do you make it your own and one
of my biggest challenges in in my
YouTube career was in working with my
agent
in the same agent as Mel Robbins and
Grant Cardone and all those guys uh
they'd give me he'd give me assignments
that never quite felt right he gave me
assignments that stretch stretch me and
ask me to tell stories that like didn't
feel quite right
uh but I still did them and in the doing
of them it's it was kind of like trying
on somebody else's hat
it didn't quite fit but it got me 80 of
the way there and it gave me a good
perspective point that then I could take
what he gave me and I just had to add my
own little customization to it and so I
love that what did you call it balancing
like your authentic self and what works
on the platform there you go yeah yeah
okay good um and then you know I can
think of of times I've been on either a
little too like the pendulum swings and
I guess it's different seasons of your
life it's okay to be one more one way or
the other but like before we had gone
into like before I met you when we
started talking shop it was way too far
to the left completely disregarding the
YouTube you know how to win on the
platform and then there are times where
like yeah to your point like you get so
into it that you start losing that
creative spark and you can't have that
either you gotta have fun I have a
little bit of both well I really think
you can you can approach it from both
ways so if you come with a great idea or
it's something like you love doing right
I would love to spend my time doing this
right that's your leading with the heart
and then you got to figure out
okay how do I make this actually work
because
if I don't figure out a way for it to
work then it's just a hobby as opposed
to something that's having a meaningful
impact at the same time though sometimes
I'll come up with things where okay this
is what's really working right now this
is what's really trending right now this
is something that you know we should be
doing but doesn't feel right so how do I
take that thing and then attach my heart
to it so thinking you can approach it
from both perspectives
um
but yeah that matching is super super
important and another thing to piggyback
because this is so real to me like this
hits home when he's talking about the
agent stretching him and doing like a
lot of the times when you do things and
you explore
like learning what doesn't work is just
as important in a lot of ways because it
like allows you to then take the little
pieces that did and build them up
um so yeah when he said that I'm like oh
man for so many times where it's like I
did things in and it wasn't quite right
but it wasn't a loss because I learned
what not to do and I also was able to
charity protect the things that were
like on point so that's number one
balance balance what's number two item
uh story and so uh this one is is almost
so obvious that it feels like a cliche
but like uh storytellers rule the world
you know and uh
uh starting out like if I would put my
arm around younger me and say the tech
doesn't matter you know the looking at
the all these things and what other
people are doing like none of it matters
if you can tell a good story you'll win
um and and I have just so many examples
of of Life handing me that lesson like
the first six months of the channel I
wrote uh some speeches told some stories
that uh audio's horrendous uh I was in
iMovie at the time didn't know how to
edit it's sloppy it just looks bad
but they did very well and when I
reshare them and point people to them
today they still do well because the
message is on brand it's on point it
connects with people uh and so yeah
that's like the the biggest thing story
always wins on this platform
um I had another example is like
it's probably like five years ago
um I wanted to take things in the next
level and I'm like linked up with some
buddies and we're like let's go to the
the desert let's go to Utah high
production uh we had drones and trucks
and cameras and wanted to make this
running thing and so excited spent more
money than I had you know and then came
back put it all together released it
the next week I wrote a speech attached
it to a still image cost zero dollars to
make and put it up and it did like 10
times better uh again YouTube's visual
so like I'm not advocating the still
image thing but like that sort of
emphasizes the point on the second one
the story worked and it the message
connected better and that's I was like
wow you know never put the cart before
the horse again you gotta have stories
so uh that's another one yeah I like it
and that is a great Storyteller if you
if you check out his channel your world
within everything that Eddie hosts there
is his own
content is his own speeches so you've
been doing it for how many years it's
almost a decade now Jesus I know I know
it's crazy you're you're a YouTube
veteran yeah it's amazing so everything
that he's posted is is his own original
Creations that then he will put b-roll
and music and photography and everything
else on top of it if you want to be a
speaker and you're doing speeches then
the story becomes critical to you can't
have a speech without a great story but
for those of you who are doing coaching
or thought leadership kinds of videos
we've talked about the template for
Thought leadership video where it starts
with a powerful opinion context sentence
raise the stakes and then story so
before you get to your advice before you
tell me about the eight ways that I can
lose weight or whatever then you need to
tell me that you understand me this is
the biggest mistake that people make
when they're creating these thought
leadership videos is you're giving me
advice but I don't know who you are
and it's easy for people to look at you
and say well it's easy for you like
great you you already look so skinny or
you already have done XYZ right it's
easy for you you don't understand me
but you do understand them because
you've been through that but they don't
know that because it's their first time
seeing you so that's where the story
becomes really important in every kind
of video so that they know what you've
been through they know that you're like
them and whether it's your story
um something in the news cycle story uh
client story if I if I say a client
story it'll usually change the gender or
change some of the things around it just
not to person identify somebody but the
story is what gets people in to feel
like this person gets me
and then they're willing to listen to
the advice
because without the story without the
connection they won't listen to the
advice so the story part is important
uh to every kind of video whether you're
doing you know speaking videos like
Eddie and your goal is to be a you know
speaker on stage or any kind of thought
leadership content as well if you want
to watch the full version of this video
as well as train live with me twice a
month to help you build your movement
and be around some other amazing people
just like you check out my movement
makers program the link to join is right
there next to me can't wait to see you
there continue to believe and go join